mom please call me back I think I'm
dating my dad
[Music]
oh no no no no
no
[Music]
dude
listen I'm so sorry we first huh
my name is Barney Stinson and I am a
recovering serial womanizer we are
likely speaking today because you are a
woman I once concocted an elaborate
scheme to have sex with
I fully understand why you've exacted
revenge on me and I apologize if I ever
a pretended to be a mannequin that came
to life and made you fall in love with
me B hired a makeup team to transform me
into a time traveling old man and told
you that the only way to stop global
warming was to sleep with young me
C told you I was Justin Hemsworth the
long lost eldest Hemsworth brother
oh my God stop talking why do I have a
feeling you have like 50 more creepy
things on that list
it's like hundreds
I did not crash into you to exact
Revenge we've never met I'm just a new
driver in the middle of the worst night
of my life
I guess I would have recognized the
three of you if we had met
you and your boobs
my STD shock therapy device it's this
experimental new electro shock treatment
for guys like me this sucker is
programmed with ten thousand problematic
words and phrases if I utter one of them
it blasts me with enough electricity to
power Staten Island
whoa
that really works
when I first saw you I wanted to say you
rear-ended me so how about I rear-end
you
but I didn't well a fun chat
what do you say I venmo you for the
damage what do you think spare like 30
40 bucks
okay 50 final offer honey my left
shoelace cost fifty dollars
this is a new low
first I find out I'm dating my maybe dad
and now I'm gonna go bankrupt because I
crashed into the fanciest curve in New
York I'm sorry you just found out you're
maybe dating you're maybe what who what
it's a long story
how about you tell me your Twisted tale
of daughter daddy lust and Intrigue and
if your story is Juicy enough
the car's on me
Lee that's a
pretty weird challenge if there's one
thing you should know about me it's that
I love a weird challenge
so my friend and I we went to this party
okay and I met a chef yeah you did yeah
yeah
[Music]